in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Amy is
with us hi Amy how are you hi Dave I'm
good how are you
welcome welcome I'm better than I
deserve where do you live
I live in Dayton Ohio very cool welcome
to Nashville and you're here to do your
debt free scream yes sir
I love it how much have you paid off 98
thousand dollars man absolutely awesome
very cool and how long did that take you
it took three years in two months
there you go love it making uh what kind
of range of income during that time
thirty-eight thousand to forty-eight
thousand okay cool what do you do for a
living I do management okay and what was
the $98,000
it was 77,000 of it was student loans I
went to a college I obviously couldn't
afford and then the other 21,000 was
cars' mm-hmm okay
and I'll take it you're single yes okay
and you make 38 or 48 thousand dollars a
year up to now 48 yes and you paid off
98 in three years you've been living on
nothing yeah I lived with my parents
ah okay and that made it work too but it
all went towards the debt then
absolutely no life no I literally just
sat in my bedroom which basically was a
closet because there was no window so my
parents were obviously thrilled to have
me back don't you get too comfortable I
love it how old are you I turned 26 I
paid off my debt on January 14th and it
was about three weeks after my 26th
birthday oh cool
so you must have started this shortly
after school yep I made my first payment
in November of 2012 like I graduated in
May 2012 and so you know I just started
throwing all my money at my debt right
away what made you decide to get this
aggressive and get rid of your student
loan debt because I realized that being
in debt for 15 years is just stupid you
should never do that okay very cool what
made you think you could do it
how did you get plugged into house I
just know that I'm very determined
and and college actually one of my
professors took a week and he taught us
your your course really yes very cool
and then I had forgotten who you were
for college and then my boss started
talking to me about you one day and I
was like that's right that's the guy
he's everywhere yeah that's funny so
what was the professor what class was
that it was a business management class
okay and what was his name
bill meek okay way to go bill meek you
change the students life right that's
that's what professors live for us to do
something that you actually go out there
and do after they finish teaching it and
this gave you the ability to believe it
could be done and should be done and
there you go so what did your mom and
dad say when you decided you were going
to embark on this plan to pay off this
debt in three years my grandpa my mom's
dad he was pretty frugal with with his
money so my dad always gave him the
nickname squeeks mm-hmm and so I am
squeeks Junior ah the ultimate
compliment who has actually two nickels
to rub together right and my dad would
make fun of me and one night at the
dinner table he said you know I really
hate to say this but they say out of
every 1,000 people there's one weird one
and I hate to say it but you're that one
weird one I was like great that's a
compliment
he's really supportive it gives you a
closet to live in calls you squeaks and
says you're weird yeah how much more of
a cheerleader could a body ask for
that's fun
your family's apparently got a good
sense of humor right that's a lot of fun
I'm hoping one just beating on you like
that half serious yeah sarcasm is our
second language in the Ramsey family so
you guys this is awesome
how does it feel you can't explain it I
mean you truly do not know what it's
like to be debt-free until your debt
free and it's so crazy because I'll get
paid and I forget I get paid because I
don't really need the money for anything
except obviously now to save and to
invest
Wow so if you got you a place yet I was
actually supposed to move out April one
with my own college roommate but she
backed out after we
sign the lease oh yeah she has a fleeced
vehicle and so it's gonna double her
miles from work to where we would live
and she just realized she couldn't do
that so I'm on a waiting list for an
apartment complex and they actually just
called and said I should be able to move
in a month earlier than what they had
planned that works out good
okay good very cool well that's you
don't have choices when you're a slave
and that's what she found and you had
the ability to do it because you're free
absolutely very cool even if your
nickname is squeaks right
- squeaks junior yeah that's good it's
wonderful you are set man you can do
anything you want to do now absolutely
if you just don't marry some guy that
messes this whole thing up you'll be all
right we need to tell him at the
rehearsal dinner that what your nickname
is right right so he knows what he's
getting into
well that's a wonderful blessing and
what character and maturity you have
shown to be sitting here at 26 years old
having paid off ninety eight thousand
dollars in debt you know the last few
weeks we've had a real run of
Millennials in here doing their debt
free screams and I think it's just to
let America know that Bernie Sanders
voters are really not who the
Millennials are there's a bunch of
Millennials like you that are
responsible and that you're not looking
for the government to fix your life you
went out there and you did this you are
a person of character and there's been a
bunch of you on here they're giving us
old people hope I'll tell you that yeah
I would never come out here because so
many people were actually very rude to
me along the process you know a lot of
my friends really yep just because you
know they have a lot of debt themselves
and you know they were basically you
know jealous and so I thought coming on
here would be bragging but then I
realized that it's inspirational and
that you know there's other people out
there listening to your show that are my
age with student loan debt and I figured
I might as well inspire them it is you
are inspiring them and you're showing me
it can be done you make forty eight
thousand dollars a year in three years
and two months you pay off ninety eight
thousand dollars and that includes your
car your student loans everything it's
very inspirational because it proves it
can be done if you have the if you have
the the character to do it the ability
to delay the pleasure and
the ability to squeak I mean that's just
that's what it takes you did it it's
awesome
so proud of you you're a hero very very
cool and you're representative of a
whole bunch of Millennials that I'm
running into that I'm very proud of
there's no there's a good bunch of you
guys out there and it's uh I think the
press is mischaracterizing you because
I'm running into as many of you as I do
the other kind so very well done all
right Amy from Dayton Ohio $98,000 paid
off in three years and two months how
you like me now count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one I'm debt free
well done well done well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind